[Music]
foreign
this is Dan Dombrowski the veterinarian
at the North Carolina Museum of Natural
Sciences he regularly works with
invertebrates and arthropods like
spiders and he's a long time Spider-Man
fan actually I learned to read on Spidey
Comics just to throw that out there we
asked him to break down all the
Spider-Man movies from the perspective
of an actual spider's Powers abilities
and romantic life
[Music]
or like me
what we do know about spiders in general
is that they're very in tune to their
their environment they they do have for
example These Fine hairs trichobathria
um we say hair even it's a modified
sitae so it's a modified structure like
a hair on their exoskeleton those are so
sensitive that they can detect movement
of of even to the level of molecules and
so a spider with these small structures
these hair like structures have the
ability potentially to interpret their
environment maybe a little more like
Daredevil honestly like you know you get
movements to these hairs from different
directions so anything from you know uh
the movement of a an animal or something
that would cause you know any any
vibrations either in their webs or in
their grounds or on the ground they
could pick up and so I'm gonna go out on
a limb and I'm gonna say you know what
that that sounds like a spider sense to
me
[Music]
spiders are are pretty strong compared
to their their sort of other sized
arthropods so measurements for for
spider strength anywhere from maybe 30
to 50 times their their body size up to
about 200 times their weight they can
lift things 200 times their size that's
pretty impressive if we had a man that
could lift you know 50 times 100 times I
think when you start looking at the the
things he lifts we're probably getting
close to that
weird spider eyes in general they're
they're similar to to mammal eyes or our
eyes and they're kind of like camera
eyes you know they've got a lens they've
got sort of a focal distance uh but but
spiders the the difference is the
outside of their eyes is at a fixed
point if you imagine when you look
through a telescope but they can kind of
move the inside of their eye around in
different places to focus on different
things and so depends the species you
look at in general a lot of Web building
or sort of these orb web spiders
probably don't have great vision but
when you get into things like jumping
spiders they they have really actually
probably very good Vision they can see a
lot of color they can see more color
than we can actually in a UV spectrum
they can probably the world probably
looks completely different to them
that came out of you yeah you can't do
that huh no how on Earth so where
spiders release their webbing typically
are from Little appendages on their back
end called spinnerets they produce web
but they do not shoot web out of their
wrists or out of their arms there are a
lot of numbers out there in general
spider silk or webbing threads are about
five times the strength of of Steel at
those same weights or at the same
comparable weights cereal is really
heavy spider silk and these web lines
are really flexible which is another
really neat trait so between being
stretchy and flexible and five times the
strength of steel you know I mean it's
pretty amazing I don't know that
Spider-Man could actually sort of spray
web on a window and then swing from it
without either losing his adhesion at
the the site where the web sticks or
pulling the window out their web can be
sticky but they control how sticky it is
and I think that would be the the weak
point in spinning webs and and swinging
from
Hey kid
[Music]
we are learning that spiders probably
are attuned to their uh to some of these
sort of electrostatic things or
situations in their environment where
um spiders do something called
ballooning where a lot of species how
they can disperse from wherever they
sort of leave their egg Sac they spin a
little bit of web and then we thought
that that they did this and then the
wind would pick it up and we thought you
know the wind just blows them around and
they land somewhere what we're
understanding now is that it's actually
a lot cooler than that they spin this
web that has a very negative charge so
this electrostatic charge of the web
really repulses the ground and materials
on the ground and can get into these
electrostatic fields in the air can
Spider-Man turn invisible not in my
universe
the other power that Miles has that's
really cool is his camouflage and there
actually are a lot of spiders that blend
in really well with their surroundings
there are a few species of crab spiders
that they tend to live on white or
yellow uh species of flowers and they
blend in amazingly well and they
actually change colors it takes days to
weeks to kind of make that color it's
not instantaneous but as far as
camouflage they're amazing combining the
genetic information from all these
Fighters into these 15 genetically
designed super spiders so Peter and
miles and the other uh folks in the
Spider-Man suits the spider-verse are
pretty lucky they didn't get all of the
spider traits really the big difference
between us and spiders is their
exoskeleton they've got their Skeleton
on the outside there could be some
advantages to this but there also are
some disadvantages injuries wouldn't
heal quite as well if they had to grow
or you know Spider-Man's a teenager he'd
have to go shed his his exoskeleton
somewhere uh periodically to to grow
that might be a little inconvenient if
Peter were to change more get more sort
of internal traits of a spider in his
anatomy and physiology some ways that
that may present spiders in general we
breathe through our our mouth or our you
know respiratory tract is attached to
our mouth and our lungs spiders
typically breathe through book lungs
they have little openings in the bottom
of their abdomen and so they breathe
through again their back end kind of
near where their silk comes from so that
would be an interesting change if
Spider-Man was kind of breathing from
his abdomen instead of his mouth another
difference with spiders I don't know how
this would present externally but their
circulatory system uh is their heart and
and their most of their sort of
contained circulatory system is dorsal
or is on their sort of top part and
their nervous system is ventral on their
their bottom side and so again I don't
know how that would present visually
with Spider-Man but it might be that you
know injuries to to some different
places would uh you know be a problem
that you know he might not be as
sensitive to back injuries but a punch
to the stomach May sort of knock him out
or be like a spinal injury
lunch
me again
so oh spidey's most sort of famous or
known uh Arch enemies or villains that
he battles with probably the lizard is a
pretty appropriate one you know spiders
although they're amazing predators in
their environment they're also really
food for just about anything that can
catch them and so I think a really cool
villain predator of spiders is one
that's uh uh called a tarantula hawk
wasp the tarantula hawk and so it's this
really big impressive vesped wasp that
hunts spiders it hunts tarantulas so you
know big prey and when it finds them it
sort of battles and fights with the
tarantula so I mean it's a lot like a
spider Spider-Man scene this wasp is
trying to Sting the tarantula so that it
can basically paralyze it and then it's
gonna take it back to its its nest or
its burrow lay an egg on it and while
that spider is alive that little egg is
going to hatch and the larval wasp is
going to develop by eating the spider
very carefully keeping it alive as long
as possible so it's fresh before it then
can turn into an adult wasp the other
thing it could be it could be a
hummingbird man I gotta be honest even
things like hummingbirds eat tons of
spiders they use spider webs in their
nests and a big part of their diet is
spiders and so that wouldn't be uh maybe
that would be the the G version for
Spidey comics
foreign
[Music]
spiders when they they mature into males
are all about Romance the Spider-Man
kiss uh with with MJ I will say I think
the the pose of Spider-Man sort of
hanging from a web upside down gets back
to being more like a spider the kiss
maybe not so much spiders just just to
start with a lot of folks haven't seen a
spider mouth if you've seen a spider
you've probably seen their chalicera and
their fangs and their Petty palps and
kind of the front end of the spider
their mouth is like it actually isn't a
kind of a permanent little pucker down
behind all that and it's a little
opening that they use to kind of slurp
the digestive juices up off of their
food so they're probably in a kissing
pose but it'd be pretty hard to get past
those chalicer and fangs to actually
kiss this beats all other meatloaf
nobody likes you middle
eating food like a spider for Peter
Parker that would be probably a spider
power he would not would not appreciate
I think Spider-Man you know being
venomous how they eat their food they
inject a Venom into their prey but that
Venom is really a cocktail of enzymes
and proteins and and really they're
starting to digest their prey so an orb
weaver or a web spider a lot of times
we'll go and inject that sort of
cocktail of Venom there's a lot of
different components in it into uh sort
of a rolled up and a silk food item and
sometimes leave it there for a while and
then they go and they kind of through
their little mouth they kind of slurp up
the the slurry that's produced and so
sometimes they'll even spit some back
and slurp some in it's kind of this
action of of
um they're squeezing and pushing and
smashing usually arthropods so you know
if you think exoskeleton arthropod it's
kind of like a juice box
yeah
one thing I would say and this is more
about Spider-Man and the spider verse
and you know looking at this stuff the
truth is how science works there's so
much here we don't know you know as a
veterinarian as a scientist we're
learning new things all the time and a
lot of times you know Stan Lee back then
thinking of things Spider-Man can do
we're actually just kind of figuring
that out or discovering it now and so I
think science is wide open uh you throw
in the Multiverse and there's little
variations on different Earths and I
think you know it's it's okay I think uh
I'm okay saying it's you know with
genetic modification of spiders and some
radiation I think you could get there on
on some version of Earth and if you're
ever in the Raleigh North Carolina stop
by and visit us at the North Carolina
Museum of Natural Sciences I'm the
veterinarian here and I actually uh have
a clinic with a window it's called
window on Animal Health where on a
couple days a week folks can come by and
visit and interact with us at the window
maybe see us working on a spider we also
happen to have a special exhibition
right now it'll be here at the Museum
through October 2023 on spiders called
fear to Fascination so the museum is
free to the public so anybody can come
in there's a small fee for the special
exhibition but come visit us if you're
in town
[Music]
foreign